you w't tell me what Maroon 5 means ask
Billy Joel Billy Joel knows yeah I heard
that you told Billy he's the only one
who knows right yeah he got us at dinner
he like sat down at our table and I was
like holy this Billy Joel
and this was like day one of success we
didn't know what we were like noou we
noou in New York right and uh and Billy
Joel sit down and he was like all right
so where'd you get the name and I'm like
I'm like didn't hear what he said cuz
I'm like that's Billy
Joel We like I not like what am
I going to do like an like not
tell him and I was like all right you
can't tell anybody but you're the only
person will ever tell and I I broke I
broke the uh the trust but you guys were
there you so you guys signed off on it
yeah absolutely you tell Billy Joel of
course no one say no to Billy no yeah
you know what the sad part of that story
probably is probably Billy doesn't even
remember what you told him a
100,000% and also by the way the
dumbest story in the world that no one
would remember you know what's so funny
I'm thinking about I had harly Simon on
years ago and she whispered in my ear
who the three people were that you're so
vinous about she had never told anyone
who the three people were she said I
feel so good about you she whispered in
my ear the name of the three people and
about five minutes later Robin comes
walking up to me and says well who who
are the people and I go you know I just
forgot I was like the only guy was
supposed to
know